Are you not entertained? Is this not why
you are here?
Spectator sports. Ancient Greece
776. The Olympic Games central to Greek
pagan culture and held in honor of Zeus.
These games were a form of worship.
Physical excellence was a way to glorify
the gods. Ancient Rome. Roman
spectacles,
gladiatorial combat, chariot races, and
theatrical performances reinforcing
loyalty to gods and the state to keep
the populace content and distracted.
Prevent uprisings away from societal
problems or political corruption to
Super Bowl Sunday as a holy day of
obligation. That game was fixed. What
you mean? It's like, bro, this NBA is
entertainment. The sports ring for sure.
It's just all scripted.
You poor naive chump by your mouth.